we would be remiss if we did not at
least mention
that
um covid is in some sense the greatest
argument against genetically modified
organisms that one could possibly
imagine that the evidence which is now
in my opinion quite overwhelming that
this virus was
enhanced and modified
uh in a laboratory presumably the
laboratory in Wuhan
um means that this is a genetically
modified organism and one thing it has
done is it has demonstrated that you are
playing with a kind of biological power
that uh you know we are able to enhance
the infectivity but we are not able to
manage control once the virus has
escaped so
um you know as strange as it sounds
I think really the battle over covid and
the battle over
um genetically modified organisms are
one our one story
um
yes because life is a continent and the
laws of Life are a Continuum whether
it's viruses or bacterials seeds and
plants or human beings
and and now that the landsat could
mission on the origins of kovid and
Jeffrey Sachs was the chair has come out
so clearly
saying it was a Lab Escape
it wasn't a market it wasn't a wet
Market I think you're getting very
conservative groups
recognizing that this was genetically
engineered
and it's an Escape
and and there needs to be accountability
accountability of those who funded this
totally Reckless research because it is
biological Belfair you know it's a tool
of biological warfare to try and
actually design viruses that harm
and you know you don't do it in a in a
society where you don't want to cause
harm to deliberately want to use the
tools of biological manipulation to
cause harm is biological warfare
and
and I think so much is now coming out of
the very tight little group you know
which was running all this faking the
signs
taking public money and siphoning on for
anti-people research and and I think it
should be a wake-up call for how
how life and biological systems have to
be kept in the comments of the common
good not become
tools for
harming other countries people and then
of course having no control and no
systems or bringing it back because
there is in GMOs once it's released
there's nothing like a recall
decide you can ban it with the GMO once
it's out it's out so
I think between the failure of the cgmos
and the high cost
of
the virus GMO
it is time for society as a whole to
take stock of how do we want to govern
ourselves will we allow a tiny Clique of
profiteers
to run the show will they be Beyond
accountability and we'll still call it
democracy democracy is when people
lead it is not when Crooks plead yeah
and in fact the covet story
um makes all of this so clear because
you know there was a ban on gain of
function research in the United States
and Anthony fauci circumvented it the
reason that the research was happening
in Wuhan was that he offshored it to
circumvent a democratic ban because
certain people were properly alarmed by
the hazard of
um of the enhancements that were being
proposed
so it is a story that reveals as you say
a tiny click of people held the fate of
the world in their hands and
um not only did they unleash a
terrible virus one that I believe
actually
um you know the argument for the
research was that it was in danger that
a closely related virus was in danger of
Leaping to humans at any time and we
needed to come to understand it so that
we could counteract it and so there the
implication is that we didn't understand
it well enough soon enough that we might
have prevented it which is of course
nonsensed I think it was very unlikely
to jump that Gap without human help we
provided that help
and then
for reasons that you know at best were
about corporate greed we botched the
response where it might have been
controlled in the early days we might
have actually been able to uh prevent a
permanent endemic State for the virus we
failed to do it and you know what a
Calamity I I don't know how much damage
has already been done economically I
know that the estimates of loss of life
are something like 6 million already but
with a virus that is now apparently
going to be a permanent fellow traveler
of humanity the costs are literally
incalculable and
um we can't continue
even if it was simple hubris that
resulted in this we cannot have uh
Humanity subjected to this level of
disaster as the result of the hubris of
a tiny number of people
um all right that's all right yes that
said
it is inconceivable to me having spent
many several decades now thinking about
the structure of governance
it is almost inconceivable to me that
the uh the necessary structures could be
um
empowered to put control back where it
belongs and and to establish some sort
of reasonable precaution about these
Technologies uh that I think it was at
one time possible but our systems have
been so
um
corrupted by these forces it's just hard
for me to imagine how we even get there
I'm hoping you'll tell me you see a way
no we have to see a way we have to see a
way because
you know at the fact that there is a
system of control and irresponsibility
and Limitless greed
uh
we have to find new ways to organize
to
regenerate the power of the people which
is the only pie in democracy
this change will not come from the top
it will not come because suddenly a
brilliant new president
sees
it all clearly because sadly politics is
now so marriage
to corporations you know what we really
have is a corporate State everywhere and
the corporate state
will not bring the changes
to regulate the corporations so we need
much more
of solidarity among people and across
countries
[Music]